arrows are set to fly when Jeremy
Renner's Hawkeye spin-off series hits a
Disney Plus streaming platform in 2021
but it turns out that was originally a
very different plan for Marvel's both
loving Avenger that plan was to give
Clint Barton his moment in a cinematic
sermon with a feature film in the vein
of the rest of his original Avengers
brethren
somewhere along the line though Marvel
head honcho Kevin Feige had second
thoughts about continuing hawk-eyed
story in a big-screen standalone film
rather than banking on the one-off
Hawkeye flick that Renner had originally
signed on for Feige and the Marvel team
instead we imagine the hero's narrative
prospects for a small screen venture
deciding that the Hawkeye story the MCU
needed would actually benefit from a
serialized approach the Disney Plus
series will see venez arrow swinging
gotcha
officially passing the torch to the next
Hawkeye in the form of the comics fan
favorite character Kate bishop though no
deal has officially been inked for the
coveted role of Kate Hailee Steinfeld
has been circling the roll for months
and this seems like just a matter of
time before a deal is done although is
plain that a multi-episode serial will
allow for more of a deep dive into
Barton's post endgame story than a
feature film would have Feige was a bit
apprehensive about flipping the plan
luckily it doesn't sound like Renner
needed much convincing about
transitioning Hawkeye from big screen to
small venez Hawkeye has been hanging
around the MCU since a brief cameo in
2011 store followed by a full appearance
in 2012's The Avengers the character has
appeared in just three MCU films since
Avengers age of Ultron Captain America
Civil War and Avengers end game while
Batson has become a fan favorite of
sorts over the course of those films
he's frequently been relegated to
secondary status among the increasingly
crowded Avengers landscape we have met
you
[Music]
and please I don't care
this likely played a big part in
Hawkeye's transition to the small screen
of course if the ultimate goal of
Marvel's Hawkeye series is to see Barton
pass the bow to the next generation and
the series should also offer an
opportunity for MCU fans to get
acquainted with young Kate Bishop the
inclusion of bishop in the future phases
of the MCU also helps to bolster the
rumor that Feige and company are
planning for a young Avenger flick at
some point in the future one other young
Avenger has already been introduced in
the MCU the now teenaged Cassie Lang the
daughter of ant-man who and the comics
goes on to be a member of the Young
Avengers under the name stature it's
just possible that the Hawkeye series
could set up the formation of this team
although that is pure speculation at
this point in fact it's still a bit too
early to tell just what narrative
Hawkeye will take but it seems likely
that we'll be seeing a modified version
of bishops origin story the character
first appeared as a trauma survivor who
beefs up on combat training in the wake
of a brutal attack
she's thrust into heroic action by
happenstance coming to the aid of the
titular team in Young Avengers issue 1
by the time Bishop took up the hawkeye
mantle in the comics Barton had already
been killed off strangely enough it was
Captain America by way of Jessica Jones
who officially passed the Hawkeye
codename off to Bishop 2 Marvel's
creative team will clearly have to make
some changes
when adapting Bishop story for the small
screen that's however should be a fairly
easy task given the ringer that Barton
was put through during the events of
Avengers ends game it's a safe bet that
the ageing hero will be eager to pass
Sabo on to a young apprentice whatever
direction Marvel's creative team choose
to go in with Hawkeye it's clear that
the narrative ground for the series
remains more than fertile it's just as
clear that fans are beyond excited to
spend a little extra time with Barton he
is hoping that the excitement extends to
whoever steps into the fray as bishop or
KY is expected to debut on Disney Plus
in late 2021 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos by your favorite MCU characters
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]